hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the boogeyman now this is
a game that was highly recommended by
you guys and this features a lot of
interesting gameplay that is very
similar to but not identical to five
nights at freddy's a lot of the viewers
that came on Steam were telling me are
not telling me specifically but telling
the other players I want to play this
game that it was very much like it but
also unique and interesting
now there's four noises that I need to
look out for the door that closet the
vent and the window and I don't remember
what they sounded like even though I was
prompted to do that and neither do you
guys because I skipped bath that part
because this is more interesting to just
jump into it with you blind just the
same as me and unfortunately only
stumbled across this tape during the dog
it's probably watching me right now
I left a flashlight under the bed if
you've not already found it it's the
only thing they're scared of I tried
telling people the bogeyman eagle my
sister no one would believe me they
won't believe you either trust me you'll
need to learn to fight this by yourself
there is the spare batteries hidden
under the floorboard under the bed
they're kind of mixed-up sorry if you
can last long enough I'd leave you alone
like it did me eventually I hope
Oh God Oh God
Oh this is terrifying I used up all my
battery you don't think I don't see you
huh
the only thing you're scared of is a
flashlight for some goddamn reason
you're an effing real being from another
level of demons that I've never heard of
before but a flashlight uh scare you
okay so the noises that I need to look
out for of the door the closet the vent
in the window and remember what they
sound it come on stop being a baby now
close your eyes and count to ten okay
something happen on the tape and
something happened right there at the
same time what is with the tapes I don't
know I didn't pick up any tapes oh god
is that the time I'm not gonna make it
I'm not gonna make it am i I'm not gonna
make it so I mean if I look under the
bed again he might be under there but if
I look under the bed then I might get a
battery or was this just one battery for
game I don't know I don't want to talk
in case he misses her it was a shine and
then there wasn't a shine oh come on
time move faster now okay so you guys
might be very you know jumping into the
deep end of the pool in this playthrough
here but it just got very interesting
very what is it oh that didn't sound
like the vent from last hour can we look
under the bed goodie for me somehow
magically under the floorboards are
gonna keep tossing batteries at me but I
don't care because that's cool I don't
care about the logic of the situation I
care about surviving okay so even though
we've kind of rushed into this the thing
about this game is that it was very
highly recommendable
was there nothing better actually
nothing cuz if it was actually something
I'm gonna be very pissed off about this
I don't like this so I need more battery
oh hey what the hell were you doing
Crawley crew how about I look oh I gotta
hold it oh God
let go I'm light and go looking oh god
damn it Oh God to go better I heard a
roll I need it oh I see you there okay I
need it now give a gift gift gift gift
gift come on come on
I have no battery no battery get away
I've got fists of fury I'm gonna kill
you I'm gonna kill you we're gonna tell
me you're gonna kill me you're gonna
tell me well what are you waiting for
I'm dead I'm not moving
oh god I think I bugged of the game
seeing him there was scarier than him
actually jumping out at me well I did
not do that well I did not handle that
well but hey welcome to the game
everybody this is what we're doing that
was only night one okay I know I can do
better I know I can do better so I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna do it again and
this time I'm gonna be less stupid about
it because that's what I've been doing
very stupid stupid stupid okay so all I
need to do is be more conservative about
my battery and actually listen to the
noises that are presented to me and now
way I'll be able to survive without
dying a horrible horrible death
admittedly
it did take him a long time to get to me
from the last scenario oh I don't know
what that is what was that is that a
thing do I actually need to worry about
that because I was interested come on no
no no no no no no no no no okay I'm not
ready for that I'm not ready for any of
that but that was interesting because
there is a little bit of like adaptation
to the light but it's weird it's only
when I look over here it's not what I
look down directly down there there's
just a little bit of light adaptation
over time but now when I look down there
I know you don't checking under
yeah there we go that was a battery fool
that was a good one that was good bad
good battery you are a creepy ass monkey
I do not like you also apparently I can
just I'm sitting on a pole and I can
just spin 360 degrees any time I want
ain't that good for me that was nothing
what was that Oh something fell oh yeah
that's right I know what you is god damn
I was looking over there I think that
ball fell oh man this gets you on edge a
little bit not bad not bad at all I see
I don't even need to do nothing
I didn't even wait for the sound I saw
you oh I'm so good at this
give me one failure and I'm good at
games everyone ignore my Mario maker
playthrough when I say that but shut up
I'm good t-shirts on sale king of the
squirrels it might still be no you don't
it might still be available while you're
watching this is a link in the
description proceeds go to Doctors
Without Borders
who's that's someone with a whistle
that's not an owl or a bird of any kind
who is oh that is literally now okay I
did not notice that thank you
thank you buddy thanks for keeping me
comfort nice flap egde okay
I'm gonna ignore the fact that you're a
weird robotic owl I'm a continue on Oh
goodbye
fine then it did say like in the
introduction that later on in the game
there's gonna be more elements of the
game nope that are added that will
distract me from what's going on
so that it'd be harder to see now I can
only imagine this gonna go until 6 a.m.
because that seems to be the logical
procedure of these things and that's
when daybreak is gonna happen I'm gonna
survive ok thank you thanks for the
update Kayla was that your name I don't
even remember did you say your name
okay I'm fine I'm fine
I'm okay thought I heard something
we're almost done it's gonna be okay
this is just a first night just like
with all the five nights and pretty
sings the first night is easy stop that
you sassy sue don't think I'm gonna God
not come I'm not gonna come up there and
I'm not gonna punch you in the face so
I'm not even gonna believe that surrett
almost a little more a little more a
little more a little more
it was actually really cool I gotta
admit the mechanics of this one you know
it is kind of like five nights at
Freddy's but very much not because the
mechanics are more freeform even though
I'm obviously in one spot still but oh
hi cuckoo hi how's it going I didn't
know there was another clock over there
but I think cool okay so that was the
first night that's not bad but as I get
through the nights it's gonna be
incrementally more difficult as I go
along so I'm gonna keep playing and
hopefully I will not die all that much
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always those
in the next video and I enjoyed the game
thoroughly playing with my friends being
blasted drunk playing our boss